Alright guys, so here's another example for the abc-to-fitting strategy, so we got the
A leg right around here, right?
So we want to mark out the very low of the A leg, right?
Something like that, and then we got the B leg, which is the significant pullback or a
small down trend, sorry small trend in an opposite direction, which is this,
so this is the B leg, and then we got the C leg right around here,
which is this, okay, and we got the low of the B leg, sorry, how about we got the high of the
B leg right here, right? B leg high, which is our take profit area, and we got the A leg low here,
so let me delete that, we'll wait for price to fake out, before price
faked out, it created structure, so you can see lower low, lower high, lower low, lower high,
and then price broke down, price faked out, and before freaking out, before crossing this line,
price created some structure, and there we have market structure shift, and we got imbalance
just here, so if I remove the line, you can see we got the imbalance between this level,
so this whole candle is our autoblock, right, and we target
the B leg high, which is this, so that was 4.74, easy guys, you see the accuracy,
it took out the B leg high, and then it reversed, all right, so let me repeat this again, so let's
see what happened, we got the A leg, okay, we got the A leg, and then we got the B leg, right, and
then we got the C leg, the C leg created structure before taking out the low of the A leg, which is
this, and then we get, so once that low was taken out, before taking out the low price
created some structure, okay, it created structure here, it created structure here,
and these structures were taken out, so this is market structure shift, and when price took out
the level, it created some imbalance and autoblock, so this was our entry right around here,
and a beautiful trade guys, very, very simple guys, so I hope by now it's gonna be clear,
I tried my best to explain the strategy, literally my throat is hurting right now,
I don't know why, so I will repeat it once again, in the ABC structure, in the ABC
strategy, we want to identify the A leg, the B leg, and the C leg, the C leg must take out
this level, okay, which is the start of the B leg, and before, before taking out the
start of the B leg, it must create some structure, all right, and that structure gets broken here,
we got the ABC, and then we got this beautiful entry here,
wait for price to come back into the autoblock and very well you gap, and as you can see, it just
went crazily down, then you can see that we can continue this, okay, so we got the,
let's, let me show you one amazing thing about the strategy, so we got the, now this whole thing
is an A leg, this whole thing is a B leg, and this thing is a C leg, okay, so it just can't
continue forever, so let me go ahead and draw out this level, okay, so before price took out
this level, price created some structure here, and it left some imbalance, now unfortunately,
it did not hit our autoblock, which were right here, but it did fill in the imbalance around here,
and as you can see, if you would have taken the entry from this level, put your stop right
below this level, okay, you could have made another 4.21% return on the straight guys, absolutely
brilliant trading strategy, so yeah guys, I hope that things are clear enough now,
this works on any time frame, okay, if you want to sculpt, you can work on the 5 minute time frame,
also it works really really good with the one hour time frame, so what are the best pairs for
this strategy? Well honestly, every pair, according to my back testing data,
anything works with it, crypto forensics, stocks, indices, everything, so yeah guys, this was my
favorite trading strategy, and this is what I'm currently using nowadays, and it is highly profitable,
you can see these big moves, right, and yeah, so I'll see you guys in the next trading strategy,
goodbye.